ومجمل التصريحات الحوثيين بشان هذه
الضربات الامريكيه البريطانيه
محمد نعم حتى الان ليس هناك تصريحات رسميه
جاءت من قبل جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
ولكن مجمل الغارات التي شلتها شلها
التحالف الثنائي البريطاني الامريكي
استهدف اربع مدن يمنيه تقع تحت سيطره
جماعه الانصار من ضمنها صنعاء وتعز
والحديده وحجه ففي حجه [__] ف ما يعرف
بمنطقه الجر وهي منطقه زراعيه استهدفت
ايضا البارحه بسبع غارات وهذه الليله ايضا
استهدفتها بسبع غارات واستهدف ايضا في
صنعاء جبل عطان والنهدين
والحف مناطق جبليه تقع بداخل المنطقه
العاصمه صنعاء ووسط منطقه مخضه بالسكان
فايضا استهدف في تعز منطقه مقبنه وحيف
ويقال انه تم استهداف شبكه الاتصالات هنا
ونتحدث ايضا عن استهداف في الحوبان وهو
ايضا في منطقه في مد بالقد مدينه تعز
واستهدف ايضا في الحديده على طول الخط
الساحلي استهدف الدريهمي وايضا استهدفت
اللحيه واستهدف في اللحيه جبل الجدع
وبثلاث غارات واستهدف ايضا في بالقرب من
ميناء الصليف استهدفت استلف منطقه بالقرب
من ميلاء الصليف
وايضا بشكل عام هذه الاستهدافات ما الجديد
فيها هو ا عدد الغارات ففي حيان
والبرحي صنعاء كان نال النصيب الاكبر وهو
جبل عطان و ونال ما يقارب خمس غارات تعد
هذه الغارات وهي محاوله من التحالف
الثنائي البريطاني الامريكي للحد من قدرات
جماعه انصار الله في للوصول او الاستهداف
الطائرات الامريكيه والبريطانيه وايضا
القطع البحريه في البحر الاحمر لكن ما
يؤكده جماعه الانصار الله في الفترات
السابقه بانه لن تنال هذه الغارات من
قدراتهم فلديهم الامكانيات والمرونه
لتحقيق
اهدافهم ففي الاسبوع الماضي كانت كان عدد
العمليات عش ع عمليات يؤكدون كل ما حاول
الطيران البريطاني الامريكي من استهداف
قدراتهم او قصفها فهم يؤكدون في كل مره
بانهم اقوى وان عملياتهم تتوسع بشكل اك
فنحن الان امام
طرفين متعامدين كل يريد ان ينفذ اجندته
فالتحالف الثنائي البريطاني الامريكي يريد
ان يقو قدرات جماعه الانصار جماعه الانصار
الله كل مره تفاجئنا بان العمليات تتوسع
حتى انه في الفترات الاخيره استفتت بارجه
و واخر مره البارحه اعلن المتحدث العسكري
بانه اطلق صواريخ بالستيه الى ميناء
الرشراش في في اسرائيل وايضا ميناء ايلات
فنحن امام تصاعد في المنطقه في ظل عدم ك
الطرفان يريدان ان يخفضان من التصعيد
والتوتر فيما التصعيد هو الموقف السائد في
الموقف